he
what are the dicky groupies like like
because i can only imagine like how much
of the
it's crazy man because he doesn't seem
like the type of person to partake in a
lot of that activity
definitely not like but it's crazy you
may or may not have at a certain point
in time in your life
particularly been the guy to you know
maybe pick up some of that slack yeah
definitely
so so what yeah what is that like the
groupies on the road for ld or crazy
like it'll be like
a guy will walk up and be like yo my
sister suck your dick if you let her
backstage and it's just like
wow like that the stuff that you'd be
seeing in the show really you know i'm
saying it'd be
crazy like did you say where's your
sister nah
she's standing right there because
that's weird the dude the sister
literally be right next to the brother
like all that type of stuff be happening
but you know dickie's such a like a
classy guy he's a nice guy he don't even
be into the group he's like when the
groupies be rushing him and stuff he'd
be like ill gross she has herpes oh my
god there's a one chance
that i might catch this like you know
he's so cautious and he's so focused on
his dream that
he ain't even worried about the uh dude
i remember we were in tampa
and you guys did a wild splash our radio
show
in 2000 was we in the tent like outside
on the street
no but we were in uh it was right off
clearwater beach the water was still
left
and uh this was uh who else was on the
show it was
dicky i think it might have been
i remember meek mill was on the show it
was
but what's crazy is it was either the
night before or the night of
the show like the station had this deal
with this club club sky in ebor city in
tampa which was like the
most hoodest club in the [ __ ] city
right and they had dickie host
and it was so hilarious and random to
see him in that setting
because that's not his vibe whatsoever
but he bro he performed at club sky
and had all these [ __ ] bbws twerking
on them and he just
loved like it was hilarious dude it was
like
i got i hope you guys had a camera guy
that day because that was like one of
those
days where it was like i was like yo
this is crazy
like this little yeah man that's what
people love about them too because
you know when he come in the building
it's like okay he's gonna be making
people
laugh and feel good you know it's always
walking in the arms you know what i'm
saying right